today on Stark talk special edition I've
got co-host Chuck Nice and Gary O'Reilly
and we brought in our geek in Chief the
one and only Charles Liu because we talk
about all kinds of things like our
experience with time relative to a beam
of light we also talk about what our
favorite objects were in Star Trek that
came true what else we also wonder what
direction should you launch a rocket is
it straight up or is it sideways that
and more coming up on StarTalk special
edition
[Music]
this is Star Talk special edition Neil
deGrasse Tyson here you're a personal
astrophysicist and as always for these
additions we got Gary O'Reilly Gary hey
Neil performer again professional
footballer and professional announcer
and yes thank you to the soccer Universe
for Lending you to us well that's very
kind of you yeah and we got Chuck Nice
Chuck always good to see you man that's
right and to the professional soccer
Universe you're not getting them back we
got him we got him now you suckers you
lost so this is a grab bag Cosmic
queries anytime the grab bag goes
everywhere
guys we got to pull out the big guns all
right we we open the shed and we pull
out we pull out the one the only
Undisputed Charles loose
Brendan colleague he's a professor of
astronomy and physics at the City
University of New York based in Staten
Island and with The Graduate Center
there and he's got a podcast called the
universe yes which showcases uh up and
coming science Talent we need some of
that on this landscape so happening and
so here's what happens you if you don't
know Charles he will bail us out of
anything we don't otherwise know
because he's the geek in Chief
all hail Charles cocktail party Lou
because if there's anything you want to
know he's the guy at the cocktail party
that knows everything that's right great
and I count myself
High among the ranks of in the
geekiverse but in the geekiverse the
scale is infinite
and that's the man in the studio right
now okay
so you this is a cosmic queries or just
queries it's a special edition so so
Gary uh Chuck what who's first I'll go
first okay okay this these are from our
patreon audience and we love them and
bless them for their curiosity and this
is Chris Hampton's question could it be
that our Perpetual experience of time is
because of our Perpetual movement
through the fabric of space-time oh I
like that so Charles let me add to that
if nothing moved in the universe would
we have any perception of time at all
we would but it's a strange strange
concept right because as it turns out
many people will say when one
interpretation of the special theory of
relativity which talks about space and
traveling through space and traveling
through time is that everything is
always moving at the speed of light
but it's speed of light not through
regular three space but through
four-dimensional space time so you and I
we move through space and we have mass
we have space time and we're moving sort
of that equivalent of a speeded line a
photon which is a piece of light has no
mass and it's moving always at the speed
of light also so in a sense that in this
four-dimensional way of thinking instead
of a three-dimensional way of thinking
we are all always moving at the speed of
light but light itself is moving through
space faster than we are moving through
space only so this perception of time is
always a matter of what we perceive
based on where we are and how we're
moving through three-dimensional space
but also four-dimensional space-time
why am I more confused than I would say
I hate to do this but you gotta tell me
why are we always moving at the speed of
light because I know that's what
everybody is asking right now right now
why are we always moving at the speed of
the speed of light it translated from
Chuck what were you smoking before you
begin okay translation right there a
little bit of Albert Einstein 1905. okay
um think about it this way if you are
traveling say in one dimension you
measure how many you say miles per hour
you're going along in a straight line in
a straight line right but if you're
moving in two Dimensions say you're
moving diagonally like like an airplane
right moving up diagonally during
takeoff it's moving both in the
horizontal Direction and the vertical
Direction and when you take the same
time yeah and so when you take the
combination of those then you wind up
with a new velocity vector and the
amount of speed you're going doesn't
look the same as either right along the
ground or vertically Upland right right
so it's adding this Vector thing now
imagine space time being that space is
the horizontal axis time
a fourth dimension shall we say so all
three dimensions of space are this one
axis right now there's one X right okay
okay the time being now the vertical
axis exactly right or the fourth
dimension or okay right okay let's keep
going so now go it's not that hard no we
ain't done yet I'm just saying it ain't
hard yet no no go ahead then then you do
the same kind of thing where you use
kind of like the Pythagorean theorem
right for what space time does in terms
of measuring distances and velocities
and so forth and so you wind up with the
velocity that is what the speed of light
would be just through space
so we all everything is moving at that
same velocity but depending on how we're
moving through space we also move
through time a little bit differently
that Vector which toggles back and forth
between the vertical and the horizontal
is always constant wait so wait just
hold on so if we're just sitting here
having this conversation we are moving
in time time and so our we're going like
vertically right now in time because
we're not really going anywhere okay so
now light
is moving not only in time but also in
space space so now it's got let's call
it a 45 degree angle up there oh that's
the difference see light has no Mass so
it's always going horizontally only
right it's actually so since it had okay
right all right so now wait a minute
okay so now so light particles don't
actually age
all right we get we age so they're
constantly in the present
no the
one of the hypotheses that was trying to
decipher whether or not the cosmological
redshift was actually expansion universe
or not was something proposed many
decades ago uh by people like Fred Hoyle
uh who suggested that maybe the reason
we see cosmological redshift the things
move in things appearing
yes right exactly it's not expansion but
just that light as it travels it gets
tired it loses energy as it moves almost
as if it had mass
that was called a tired light hypothesis
yeah right but does it still travel at
the speed of light if it if it now so
does the nude its way through ah really
what garage just said is what is
redshifting
that's really what he just said right
thank you that's for another time but
basically it's the way the cause the
cosmos moves it expands throughout right
what used to be tiny is now huge but as
far as relativity goes and how our
motion through space-time goes right we
are this way and right that way
horizontal vertical horizontal as you
wind up with this guy who's going who's
going at an angle between us we do when
we move when we move right got it if
we're in a spaceship or on an airplane
or something like that we are going back
then there's an angle because we're not
only moving in space but also in time
okay all right that's why that's why one
of my uh College professors who really
understood this super well explain to
all of us that you can do special
relativity using hyperbolic trigonometry
and he always thought well that was much
easier yeah
which was cool uh but I never quite
understood it so well so yeah all right
well you make me feel good Charles
because if you don't quite understand it
I feel in a better place this is a tough
thing guys all right let's go to the
next one what's the next question all
right here we go that was crazy by the
way that was crazy it was good crazy
that was that was good crazy that was
crazy good question just just to put the
nail in his coffin all right so Charles
isn't it just being provocative to say
we are moving at the speed of light what
you're saying is we're moving at our
natural speed through time whatever we
want to call that light is moving at its
natural speed through space
but to say we are moving at the speed of
light that's a little needlessly
provocative it seems to me it might be
that kind of phrasing probably is an
attention grabbing device more than
anything else but it also implies with
it a need for you to understand what it
means to move through space correct
very good it forced me to think about
that differently exactly because I'm
naturally just moving forward in time at
one second per second and the light is
naturally going through space not aging
at all we're just doing our thing
however what it did do for me was it
allowed me to visualize the axes that
you were talking about that's really
what it did yeah so all right cool all
right all right Kevin this Kevin the
Samuel yeah and Kevin says glad the
luniverse is here nice nice it says if
the universe has landed
if we are able to achieve warp
capability one day will we experience
time dilation in accordance to
Einstein's general relatively Tiffany If
Star Trek is correct they age at the
same rate as Starfleet in San Francisco
P.S Neil get your hands on some Hartford
Old Vine Zinfandel from Russian River oh
nice nice Russian River actually I love
Russia but it's not cool enough anymore
the Russian River does it right and old
lines can't argue with that I love it
thank you thank you all right yeah well
well Kevin the the bottom line is that
Star Trek does it wrong right in order
for yes I know excuse me I know I know
how do I just said I know what I just
said I take that back right now
Star Trek is completely correct in the
Star Trek universe
Star Trek when it comes to warp speed
and time dilation is not correct when it
comes to our understanding of the theory
relativity so that you're saying they
shouldn't age while they're doing their
High warp maneuvers
right what what should be happening the
problem is you see the high warp
Maneuvers are faster than the flight yes
and if an object moves through our
current space at faster than the speed
of light then it can violate causality
yeah and so that whole aspect of
Relativity and so forth is necessary to
make sure that the arrow of time and the
way that we know understand history and
the changing of the universe stays okay
that's causing occur before events yes
yes when you have rather than after like
when you have a circumstance like warp
speed right that goes out the window
this object because it's in a Subspace
bubble right by the alcubier drive or
whatever it goes through so fast that it
can actually outrace a radio signal
to a distant star and so you can tell
something that happened before the radio
signal was even
arriving which means that you violate
causality the way that they get around
that problem is to say that
Communications also is faster than some
space right right so you know those
Subspace Communications and so forth
right and what that means is that I can
still radio ahead
not with a radio though but with
something that's going faster than my
spaceship going which is faster than the
speed of light at that moment and
therefore causality is not violated
because all information in that
subscribe Subspace is retained yeah okay
so
bottom line is as soon as you throw in
these fanciful ideas of how to go faster
than light
then you have to assume that your
communication is also go faster than
light and that light is no longer a
speed limit for objects in the universe
therefore causality can be preserved
because you have everything so am I
correct if that's why the Wormhole works
as uh with without that violation
because you're not actually going faster
than the speed of light moving through
the medium of space right right right
yeah should be just clean clean step
through
Yes except that wormholes at the moment
have not been determined to
exists Star Trek
universe Rick has wormholes Dr Strange
has Wormhole don't tell me we don't have
wormholes oh we have wormholes does the
universe have wormholes okay I love all
those wormholes but uh yes do we have
one right now that's that's from okay
it's good enough for Rick and Morty it's
good enough for me that's right good
morning we're gonna take a
this
thank you Chuck did we really need the
the drunken bird was that really
necessary you can't do Rick without it
without a bird all right we're we're
gonna take a quick break when we come
back more Star Talk special edition with
our geek in Chief
we're back Star Talk special edition we
got some query coming in from The Ether
and I Would by that we're defining our
patreon support as
a population in The Ether sending us
queries and this is a grab bag Edition
and we need backup for that of course
every time and that's Charles Liu so
thanks for being here Charles my
pleasure so who's next who's got the
who's got the next query coming all
right uh next up is many buyers from New
York City all my life I've always
thought there was some connection from
these three subjects time universe and
dreams like as in one is dependent on
the other in order to unlock the center
of this pyramid for answers it may be
that the answer can be a combination of
Science and philosophy but do you think
this pyramid of subjects has anything to
do with answering questions such as
the value of life or why we exist
[Music]
what a wonderful question and linking
you know linking the the universe with
some sort of metaphysics is something
that has been done since the very
beginning in fact Neil will tell you
that in the history of science until
such time as there was a true separation
between empirical science and
metaphysics it was called natural
philosophy and we were always trying to
philosophize until people like Galileo
said you know what I don't think we
should really mix like how beautiful is
a tree or or how righteous is a star
let's just talk about the tree and the
star and then worry about the philosophy
separately yeah Newton's most famous
book
uh which we call principia the full
title of that is
mathematical principles of natural
philosophy and so the very natural
philosophy is part of that framing right
point right yeah so your your ideas are
great man either right on Target and
what I would say is the following as far
as we know right now human dreams are
limited in our existence our perception
there is no evidence yet that our dreams
are actually connected with the rest of
the universe
that's the key here in terms of tying
them together for us and for our
existence dreams and time and the
universe are linked but is it true for
anything else in the universe do we know
for example do pets dream I know
sometimes we think that dogs are
dreaming when they're jumping around and
they seem very happy when they're
sleeping and things like that yeah that
kind of thing
good job very good that's like too good
actually Charles let me let me throw
this at you sure premonitions yes you
can't get the future before
you're out of the present well but I've
had I've had premonitions that have come
true right so that's the future before
right in the presence
wait a minute or is it
a convergence of the past and all of
your past that that converges on one
moment because the surroundings uh
inform you in such a way that you say oh
this is going to happen and so it
appears to you that it has already
happened but really it's just your vast
past experience coming together in one
point pre- another event
well said mate can I explain one thing
uh I'm 19 years of age I have not played
in my football club's first 11 right so
I'm I'm a way off of that and about 10
days before it actually happens I have a
dream I'm running towards my own goal
I'm in the center of the field and I get
punched in my left cheek
random random so I'm playing in my full
debut
about 10 days later I'm running towards
my own goal in the center of the field I
get punched in my left cheek I'm like
you are kidding me yellow card red card
no carried on Caroline on yeah we paid a
different game back then
oh man but for that to be part and
parcel okay of that dream way ahead of
time was just so randomly well here here
is the point right we have not yet been
able to scientifically confirm whether
these things are random or whether they
are actually connected think about this
way the human brain is essentially
designed to make predictions of the
future right we are spending our entire
existences
from the early days right we predict
that if that lion over there will come
after me in this direction therefore I
will run in that direction we predict
later on right that the stock market
will go up therefore we will invest
right these predictions do not always
come true in fact they rarely come true
but there are thousands of them the
brain is a prediction generator
so could it have been that your brain in
its generation of predictions which
dreams to some extent are right go on
and had so many predictions in your
lifetime that just that one random one
came true
just by chance and you remember the hits
and you forget the misses you forget the
missus yeah I knew I knew which stadium
I was in
and it was just it was just as drenched
so it's really remarkable that way too
and then there's a second factor which I
only recently learned from my
psychologist friends
Karen let me we humans will adjust our
memories to match backwards yes right we
humans actually have a it's hard to know
whether it's a defect or whether it's a
reality truth well if you're a black man
it's a defect
every time we remember things our brain
is recreating the memory it's drawing it
out it's not like a typical say computer
where it comes out and brings out a
perfect copy so it goes it's not a movie
camera it's not it goes through a lot of
filters and it resets things and people
wind up
misremembering not on purpose not to be
lying but their brains have actually
shifted what they thought was real from
the past right so could it be that when
you got hit in the face and maybe you
know it was similar to feeling being hit
in the face in the dream your brain set
it up so that thinking back to the dream
it wound up matching the two pieces and
getting them confused it is possible and
again like I said so many of you things
are speculation and it's hard for us to
establish what is actually
scientifically causal or the case but
that does happen and here's the problem
Gary is it you didn't write that down
when you had the dream that's part of
the challenge here of verifying it
scientifically so that leaves whatever
your dream was susceptible to exactly
what Charles is saying about when you
recover the dream so whoa this was bang
on do exactly what happened well the
dream the dream was about 10 days before
the action event happened
every single day yeah okay 999 times it
won't come true and one time it comes
true you can't then claim special I got
to get me a dream diary
also it's pretty reasonable that
um uh you could have a dream about
getting hit in the face while playing
soccer and get hit in the face
it's not it's not that
so to I guess to wrap up Manny's
question you know the idea is basically
they say dreams definitely affect Human
Experience and how humans interact with
the universe does the rest of the
universe however
sense those dreams or react as a result
of them that is something we don't know
probably not yeah it's a it's a very
probably not but
you know people still claim it
yeah yeah
and and listen it informs a lot of
people on what they do so there is a
significance there no matter what
because there are a lot of people who
are reacting to their lives based upon
you know that what they think is that
information but all right and by the way
it's another thing Charles I think uh a
dream as you know is a neurosynaptic
firings of your brain and
should that be fundamentally different
from deep thoughts you might be having
while you're not asleep so so what I
find intriguing is almost every movie
that shows somebody
who by some bolt of lightning or through
drugs becomes insanely brilliant okay
like the movie Lucy or the one
phenomenon I think it was of those kind
of drugs okay in those movies in every
one of them the person can control
things with their brain right and I'm
intrigued by that because
if they're just really smarter they
should just simply solve problems faster
or better right and they they somehow
the urge in the storytelling is to have
the power of the brain jump out of
itself right and then manifestulate
manipulate physical objects in your
environment in almost every case that's
the power they give them but from the
smartest person on earth to the dumbest
person on earth neither of them can move
stuff in front of them without touching
them so to say let's make the smart
person even smarter now they can spin
tops and and and Float objects I don't I
don't get it however the truly smart
people know how to get other people to
move stuff for them
please please
give me another question Chuck what do
you have here we go this is Camilla
kaftal who says hello Dr Lou and Dr
Tyson Camilla here from Baltimore
Maryland how is the cosmic microwave
background temperature so constant
everywhere in the universe when there
are hot stars like our sun oh
conspiracy beautiful questions
temperature
that one Charles Camilla you've asked a
great question which sometimes
astronomers don't do a good job of
explaining outward the cosmic microwave
background does get contaminated by
foreground objects so if we were just
measuring like say for example the wmap
satellite or the Kobe satellite did the
cosmic microwave energy that's reaching
us from the cosmos right what will
happen is that we will pick up the stars
in the front the Galaxy that is we're in
and the cosmic microwave background in
the back the trick that astronomers do
it's not a trick it's really hard work
it's actually getting rid of that
foreground signal so your Insight is
exactly right Camilla the cosmic
microwave background is contaminated it
is there was a result that reported some
new discovery in the cosmic background
and it was later found that they did not
properly remove the effects of our
galaxy correct and it happens a lot it's
like for a race it's like the erase
feature on your phone
foreground contamination is actually one
of the things in astronomy that we have
to worry about much more than say a
typical laboratory physicist they can
try to remove as much of the foreground
as possible but we're stuck looking
through the gas and the dust and the
stars and the galaxies
yeah yeah we can't change it but we're
very cool you know very cool fun stuff
thank you question yeah Gary what do you
got okay Colin
um if a black hole is infinitely dense
why are some bigger than others
um
good question first of all Kyle you know
it's not always about size okay that's
number one
oh well that sounds like somebody might
need some size I I don't know oh Chuck
I'll I'll I'll leave you uh to ponder
that one uh here's the story okay
a black hole is not infinitely dense the
only part of a black hole that's
infinitely dense is its Singularity see
a black hole
The Event Horizon that surrounds it the
edge shall we say of the black hole
contains a certain amount of mass within
that container the average mass is
always less than infinity
it is just in the spot where we think
exists The Singularity where the density
is so now here's the question well just
to be clear just to be clear so when we
describe the size of a black hole it's
the size of the Event Horizon just for
practical purposes to describe how big
things are but the matter is deep within
normally we think of the size of the
Earth as the edge of the matter of the
Earth but the black hole we just go to
the event horizon and we're happy with
that okay right we do not know what's
inside we don't we know it's distributed
so if that's the case right it means
that if it were a star at one point I'm
not talking about a supermassive at the
center of a galaxy I'm talking about
just a star that collapses in on itself
we know that that star had a certain
Mass before it collapsed in upon itself
so if it had a certain Mass before it
collapsed in upon itself how can the
density of that mass become infinite at
one single point if it started off with
a finite Mass
the mass itself doesn't become infinite
but the density becomes okay so for
example uh Mass let's say something is
is that the weight of my head or
something but if I squish my head very
small right as a black hole would do if
I fall into it right uh it would become
more dense but not more massive okay it
would still take the same amount of
energy or Force to lift my head all
right but you would need a smaller
container as an example
I was going to say that was a painful it
just popped into my head use a
watermelon or something you know so now
wait a minute I don't have a head for
those kinds of jokes so Chuck Low Chuck
Lou here's the deal yeah uh
if that's the case how can something
become infinitely smaller and smaller
and smaller and smaller at some point it
doesn't have to just be so tightly
compact that it can't get any smaller
great question Chuck and in fact it is
the people who study matter mostly
Quantum physicists who say that yes
there it must be a limit
but when Albert Einstein established a
general theory of relativity he did not
see it he did not he was not happy with
the fact that the mathematical equations
of space-time allowed for the existence
of these singularities that's why
they're called singularities right
because they they don't follow the
mathematical rules that you would expect
for uh the space it's where God is
dividing by zero oh my gosh who said
that
it's kind of it's kind of yeah Neil is
right that's exactly what it is you're
dividing by zero you're creating
something that should not exist if
you've never done that before do it on
your calculator see what happens can you
then make this thing that's reducing
inside disappear altogether or does it
reappear somewhere else don't know the
current hypotheses suggests that black
holes are not say tears in space-time in
which case the matter or the mass would
flow from one point to another but
rather it kind of like a like a hernia
in space-time a water balloon where the
mass goes in and kind of collects in a
space or a time or something that's not
part of the space-time we have access to
and then over many many trillions and
trillions of years slowly gets expended
outward again through the process called
Hawking radiation
so check it out because Neil said do it
I just divide it by zero or my so the
first time I did it I did Zero by
divided by zero and it said invalid
format please do not do and then the
second and then the second time I put
one divided by zero and it said can't
divide by zero and then the third time I
did it and it went no
the fourth time you did it said I
already told you no
go to your room
go to your room but it's the examination
of these singularities and unusual
points in the equations of space-time
that have led to these amazing
discoveries and thought processes like
black holes like the big bang like those
kinds of things that we're wondering
about today that fire our imagination
that's right all right we gotta take
another quick break when we come back
the third and final segment of start
talk special edition with our geek in
Chief Charles
we're back for the third and final
segment of StarTalk special edition with
Chuck Nice Gary O'Reilly
geek and chief Charles Liu Charles how
do we find you on the internet
oh well I am at Chuck Liu
c-h-u-c-k-l-i-u and you can find me on
the universe channel uh just chatting
about General things there's the podcast
and there's also various equipment and
there's also various content that we
talk about in there share with all the
people who follow it's always a pleasure
to do that I mean other kind of fun
content posted content yeah that's good
yeah yeah all right all right let's go
to the next question this special
edition Cosmic queries okay all these
questions yeah thank you all these
questions from our patreon audience so
uh thank you very much for your
curiosity Craig Caldwell from the UK
please can you briefly explain how it is
more efficient and easier to launch a
rocket going directly up rather than
taking off similar to an airplane does
uh so answers please now Gary could you
please do that again but do it in Craig
cardwell's accent
because you're both Brits okay I don't
know what part of it I don't know what
part of the UK
so the the answer to the question
actually is
that we do try to launch our Rockets
horizontally
when you see on the launch pad
a rocket going upward vertically
the only reason it tries to go up first
is because it's trying to build up speed
because it will then start curling
sideways it starts moving horizontally
because the best way to get into orbit
or out of the gravitational well of a
planet is to travel at a tangent not
straight up vertical it's only up
vertically to get off of the ground away
from the launch pad over mountains and
so forth and then the trajectory starts
to curl right that's why for example we
launched from Florida because it goes up
for a short while and then goes
horizontally over the Atlantic Ocean so
our sense that we launch vertically is
actually just those first few seconds of
our perception later on if you want to
go further and further upward while
you're in orbit you move tangentially
you move horizontally and that actually
has been shown mathematically and and
Engineering wise to be the most
efficient way to gain altitude up in
space
once you're outside of the slowing down
effects of the atmosphere of the earth
so Charles here's something amazing you
ready yes the exact trajectory of a
rocket you know what it is
it's an exact trajectory do you know
I'll tell you what it is uh it is it is
this it is the inverted that the
physically inverted solution to the
brachistochrome problem no kidding yes
wow yes I was gonna guess catenary but
because it makes more sense let's wait
think about it makes much more sense
yeah yeah it makes yeah right
I don't think yeah of course the ice
cream cone problem everybody knows that
yeah so here's there was a there was a
was it Bernoulli someone posed a some
famous uh mathematician of of from the
19th century pose the question might
have been the 18th century post the
question if I have a ball up here and I
wanted to get down over
down but over to the right a little
what path should I take should I put a
plank connecting the two of them and
roll it down will that get there faster
than if it drops first and then curls
around at the bottom yeah okay is there
a shape
is there an arc that I could drop this
ball will get to that point at a lower
elevation the fastest this turned out to
be a very hard problem and it is not the
straight line
right there is a curve where it builds
up speed falling and then that speed
gets forward moves It Forward very
quickly and the minimization of that is
a we learn this in advanced mechanics
right and I think that's when I did uh
Charles we uh what what class did you
learn that I think I was I might have I
think I think we got it as a bonus from
my uh calculus yeah yeah my calculus
teacher in high school brilliant man in
fact went on to write some really great
books you know review books about
calculus and he would throw in just
these little things like oh by the way
you know that's what kind of made math
class cooler because math can be just
like learning grammar or learning
punctuation or learning vocabulary learn
extra little tricks and tricks and fun
things when you put them into like hey
was this useful in some way was this a
thing that you actually find out you
know those are the opportunities where
you make connections and go aha this
math stuff is cool
from the ice cream cone principle
we haven't diverged we've we've embraced
it Chuck as Gary just said it brings it
to life now I bet there are thousands of
people out in the podcast first that are
wondering what's the ice cream cone
problem and now they're going to look it
up and now they're going to learn math
which is based on ice cream because they
like it it livens up the subject what is
the ice cream cone problem you said that
no sprinkles the exact inverse of a
trajectory of of rockets back inverse of
the ice cream cone oh yeah yeah sorry I
was not
the breakfast
oh oh excuse me the bro christochrome
what's the ice cream cone which is very
much like
um uh cookies and cream what's your new
flavor especially
let me tell you something Neil if they
ever give you a Ben Jerry's ice cream
but my only point is this this math
exercise
is designed to find the fastest minimum
energy path between these two points
right and so so the minimum no just down
and and to the point you take that flip
it up it is the minimum energy
expenditure into orbit because if you go
up too high first you wasted too much
energy gaining altitude if you go
downwind first you're wasting too much
energy trying to go horizontal so it's
the it's the perfect uh inversion of
that problem that's why it's great is
there a way to Launch
by spinning
oh and then watching that way this this
is actually a startup company I heard
about this
um yeah just recently yeah a startup
company would you like to buy my shares
they want to spin yes something to Heist
to launch speeds right yep there you go
right and so they're not even using a
rocket it's just no it's like what's
what's this what would be the equivalent
earlier when you put the astronaut in
the centrifuge type thing it's been like
an old-fashioned spinner yeah like a
medieval kid yeah
you could not throw an asteroid yeah
it's it's it's it's like a medievable it
spins around and then releases
right you can't send an astronaut in
there though they'll insides will turn
to jelly I mean they're gonna leave the
Catapult
at like a thousand miles an hour you
know just like sudden the g-forcism
does this have a commercial
it has it has been thought for a long
time that the easiest way or the least
energy way to get payloads up into space
is just create a tether basically an
elevator going from ground Stairway to
thousands of miles in the air and just
go up up up up up up up up that'd be
great but wait a second let me ask you
this there are two ways um you can go
backward in the long run I mean still
time to change the roads are wrong is
jet fuel cheaper than rocket fuel at the
moment yes by the way so then why is it
that we were transporting the shuttle
when it's here on Earth by piggybacking
it on a on the back of a big jet but we
wouldn't put it into space by
piggybacking it up to the highest
altitude possible detaching it and then
letting it just fire Rockets to go into
space
because the atmosphere is a lot thinner
and you got a lot a lot less uh space to
go that kind of strategy is actually
what was done in the early rocket Plains
in the early spacecraft okay in fact
some some spacecraft now for example I
think one of the commercial spacecraft
done by some billionaire or another
right reaches Space by doing precisely
that you carry some sort of a rocket on
some sort of a plane and then you let
the rocket go and then the rocket takes
it the rest of the wing let's try to get
a couple more questions in here before
that third and final segment ends who's
next all right I'll jump in with this
one because uh this is an interesting
one uh back to Star Trek just as a
spoiler Connor home
um in Star Trek what is your favorite
example of a scientific prediction slash
concept that actually became true but
wasn't proven at the time oh I know my
answer but I want to hear everybody
else's answer I have an answer but I
don't know if it would I don't know if
it fits okay so here's here's my answer
my favorite thing that has come true
is the communicator
yeah indeed all we have to do today is
to pick up something a little
rectangular and say Scotty
right and Scotty can hear you yes
Captain oh sorry that's Checker uh same
same idea get your accent straight dude
okay yeah you're worse than me hi in
fact our communicators are way more
advanced than anything than anything
right correct that's correct okay
just touches his star Fleet badge right
and all of a sudden he owns up comes
that sort of touch that touch activity
on smartphones that we that didn't exist
at the time that now does that's right
okay it's amazing mine would be talking
to your computer and the computer talks
backwards their form of uh artificial
intelligence computer please tell me
that the computer would give you
information so and we have that today
like that's not science fiction that's a
great point right very good point right
okay and they don't use keyboards right
that's not a thing yeah yeah yeah is it
my turn here okay yes it is but Gary did
you give your answer I did that you
touched the Starfleet badge and all of
them so
I have two answers one which I never
thought would ever happen happened we
could just walk up to a door and it will
open
but wait even then you could go to a
supermarket no the supermarkets of the
day they have a pad touch pad and you
step on the pad it would complete a
circuit and that would open the door
okay but there were no pads they would
just walk up to the door just somehow
knew that they were there the two guys
on either side of the door going yeah
the bush production must have had a
blast with that shot so I I was I said I
believe the photon Torpedoes the aliens
the warp drive the door opening just my
walking up to it never okay
another one I don't think it was
developed yet even if the science was
there and maybe they wouldn't have known
about it but they have this machine that
instantly Heats food
which is basically be a modern
um
well I don't know if it's a replicator
or it's just something that makes the
hot food
I mean the replicator doesn't
necessarily heat it right so there's
this this cavity where I want some
chicken soup they push a button and hot
sick and chicken soup I count that like
as a microwave oven that's the original
Star Trek yeah I know but is that not a
precursor to 3D printing
well the replicator is a precursor yeah
the replicator the replicator would be
the 3D printing yeah right yeah so
that's that's that's the other one that
we've got to consider as well and you
know there was a big prize was it an X
prize even that was announced uh try
quarter the tricorder yes yes tell
everybody about that oh well tricorder
was the thing that bones waved over
somebody and figured out exactly what
was wrong with them medically I'm a
doctor not a computer technician right
I'm a doctor not a fill in the blank
right so the whole point was
that if we somehow could do the same
through uh remote sensing just wave
something over somebody and get all
kinds of things vital signs things like
that we're getting close already
actually for example now we can take
people's temperatures without touching
them right the thing and then you get
the radio you know the infrared off of
the surface there's a NASA NASA thing by
the way that's right oh absolutely yeah
for a track order to work would you need
to have certain implants in the body
but it would happen he's lucky just
scanning a code then aren't you that's
right that would be very useful but it
would not be necessary the whole point
of the tricorder is that you can just
diagnose what's wrong just by remote
sensing okay but you know we're really
close already because we're using light
so that you know a lot of these
instrumentations uses light to actually
get the reading from the body so so
Charles are there two kinds of of tools
and one of them is receiving whatever
your body is giving it so if your body's
like radiating a little warmer you see
that extra high temperature it's a
massive passive but another one maybe
you'd have to like have the person walk
in front of X-rays and then it reads
something that you've actually put
through the body right so the top the
Doppler radar for weather forecasting
for example you do that you send a radar
pulse down to the ground it comes back
up and depending on what it's like when
it comes back up what the time delay is
how strong it is and things like that
you know whether there were clouds
whether it's raining whether it's clear
or how much rain there was even yeah by
the same token maybe it can sense some
sort of pulse a harmless piece of
information uh radiation down through
the body or onto the skin when it
bounces back it can read the results and
see ah yes this person has a skin
infection this kind on their you know
that part of their skin and therefore we
need to cut off their arm oh no anyhow
guys we're out of time
it's a good question to end on that was
fun very good start talk special edition
with the one Charles Lou Charles thanks
for coming in for this always a pleasure
thank you so much
I'm disputed
you can shake Charles you guys are too
kind thank you all right start talk
special edition signing out Neil
deGrasse Tyson keep looking up
foreign